One day, a farmer said to his wife, "We don't often use our horse."
"Shall we sell it?"
"Then, sell it," his wife said.
"You are always right."
The farmer set off for the market.
A friend of the farmer came up to him.
"Are you crazy?" He asked.
"What will your wife say when she sees the rotten apples?"
"She'll kiss me and tell me how clever I am," the farmer said.
"I'll bet you a bar of gold that she doesn't," the friend said.
"I'll bet you everything I have that my wife will think I am clever," the farmer said.
He went back to his farm and his friend came, too.
His wife was waiting at the door for him.
"Hello, my dear," the farmer said.
"I gave a man our horse for his cow."
"That was very clever of you," the wife said.
"Then, I gave another man the cow for his sheep," the farmer said.
"Oh, that was a very good thing to do," his wife said.
"What a clever man you are!"
"Then, I gave another man the sheep for his goose."
"Oh, I love eating goose eggs," his wife said.
"But I then gave a man the goose for his hen," the farmer said.
"A hen's eggs are much better than a goose's eggs," his wife said.
"But then, I gave a man the hen for a sack of rotten apples," the farmer said.
"Oh, I am so glad," his wife said.
"I went to our neighbor to borrow some herbs."
"'I have nothing to give you for them,' I said to her."
"'I don't even have any rotten apples.'"
The farmer's wife put her arms around her husband and kissed him.
"Now, I can give her some rotten apples," she said.
His friend was very surprised.
"You have won the bet," he said.
"Here is the bar of gold."
"You are the luckiest man in the world!"
"You have a wife who always agrees with you."